congratulations on the movie
love it it's uh it's just so good you
know
oh thank you i'm sure you're hearing
that from everyone though it's a very
tough day for doing interviews
well it's such a struggle no do you know
what it's so
it's so lovely to hear because obviously
this is
you know we filmed the movie like two
years ago now it's been a
delayed a year on release so sometimes
the longer it goes on
the more worried you become because it's
the suspense
but to hear you know some of the kind of
opinions and reviews that have been
coming out from people it's just been so
it's been so lovely
uh i am curious this is your first big
hollywood movie
so what what did you what was the
experience like in terms of what did you
expect going in
and what did it actually turn out being
going into it i was so intimidated um
i was terrified because i'd
predominantly done television and i'd
always
had this conversation in my head of that
there were tv actresses and there were
film actresses and i was probably
destined to be a tv
actress which isn't even a thing but
that was obviously my own insecurity
um and i think i thought that there was
it would be so different
and to me it was like oh this is exactly
the same
you know you you prepare in the same way
that people are as committed as lovely
you know all working together for the
same thing
it's just on a much much bigger scale
you know it was the grandeur of it um
and just realizing um
how much that goes into a movie um
like this i think was my biggest um
kind of shock on learning learning kev
yeah sure uh one of the things about
this film is uh
sean told me that him and ryan added a
lot in post-production some
jokes uh you know and also all the vfx
are in post-production what was your
reaction seeing the finished film versus
what you
maybe thought it was gonna be it was
amazing because
when i first got the script i was like
wow how are they gonna
how are they gonna interpret this on
screen of you know
being the real world and the video game
i didn't know how the two are going to
merge
and having very very rarely worked with
green screen i mean probably the most
i've worked with green screen is like
one green wall
and then this was like some days going
into a big green box of a studio
and having to act out very physical
things you know you're having to use
your imagination a lot
i mean the guys were incredible they
know they treated me storyboards and um
you know to try and help me visualize it
but i have to say it was probably the
most enjoyable part
um of watching it was seeing
how everyone else's work has come into
play and
um seeing everyone else's vision i mean
there's so much to take in
i feel like it's gonna be one of those
films like the more you watch it the
more you'll see
yeah there's a lot going on in the
background before i run out of time with
you
i'm kind of excited for ridley scott's
new movie that you're in
um just kind of um
what was the experience what was the
experience like working with him because
a lot of people don't realize that
he works incredibly fast sometimes
you're lucky to get
two takes you know like he is he's a
unique filmmaker so can you sort of talk
about making the film with him and
you know stuff like that absolutely i
mean that was a dream come true
um and you're right he does work very
fast he has like
four or five cameras rolling the entire
time um
which i have to say kind of spoiled me
because then you go on to another set
and it's maybe one camera and you're
like
oh so we're gonna be on this for 12
hours today
great you know it's like there's
something about the
um you know
a camera being on everyone and everyone
having to be on their a game
and he's so meticulous and he knows
exactly what he wants in regards to
set and how the camera is set up and
what he wants to look like but i do have
to say like
even though he shoots quickly he's very
generous
and um you know there's always space for
you to do another take and i think he
really enjoys you kind of playing around
and maybe giving him something which he
wasn't
expecting um but that film i'm
so proud of that film um and i think the
way in which they tackled the story
um and the execution of it is is
is is phenomenal so i really hope that
you enjoy it
i really do i cannot wait on that note i
gotta go
again love free guy congrats on being
part of it wishing nothing but the best
it was so lovely to meet you